hello there
reject nation I'm Craig Alba I'm John
Humphrey we're gonna watch the Skywalker
son trailer this is from a youtuber
named Alex Segal this is a trailer for
the Skywalker saga in the style of the
rise of Skywalker trailer love these
kind of edits this is a topper war to
your video request from a handsome
Canadian son of a bee the Lance door
Lance D Lance big beam let's do this
Lance bde you know what I'm talking
about
no no one-stop Lance
[Music]
the belonging you seek is not behind you
he desire I want her to wait for the
fourth week of June dreaming to become
each other is not an easy challenge I'm
not afraid body
[Music]
[Music]
very good job
taking one last look this is Threepio
sog I never looked at it that way
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
[Music]
laser swords Sona
nice that was great it's such a good
slice big transition
with you
[Music]
[Music]
that was really well edited yeah I was
well done I was really well sliced but
it goes together pretty well yeah
surprising like well you know I mean
things get more glossy and higher
technology over time and whatnot yeah
yeah the only time we call the attention
to itself as Wendy you know the audio
from the older phones especially like a
new hope it sounds distinguished ly
different Luke starts talking I want to
learn the ways of the force and become a
Jedi like my father literally different
yeah you're a different kind of quality
and hiss yeah if I was Chris but you
know you can't really work around so for
what we got here this got me pretty
excited to see Raisa Skywalker to
include the saga before we pick it up
again and off into something new or
maybe go back and decide we can't leave
the Skywalker's behind for that long I
thought the editing editing trance
transitions transverse oh well done here
really following the motion of the last
shot and then to the next scene I mean
it sounds like basic trailer editing but
you got to keep in mind this guy sourced
footage from eight movies plus a bunch
of trailer footage for the night movie
so this is not easy to compose like you
got to go through a hell of a lot of
stuff to make sure this all flows really
well I'm keeping it focused on the
Skywalker saga the other part that's to
feel like you're really for long as
anything with Rey who just kind of weird
to me well yeah because she feels random
if you don't understand but then again I
think this will all feel kind of random
if you don't understand yeah the
connection feels dubious because there's
such a clear build-up with Luke
literally cutting back and forth and
looking at his dad's origin with Anakin
and stuff right yeah that's kind of call
attention to the fact that like then you
got all these new people yeah that we
didn't see like intermingling in the
last bunch of footage yeah it is a
little funny but I think this does a
really nice job of sweeping up the
emotion and since the Star Wars it's the
physical it's the imagery it's the
iconography it's the feeling that Star
Wars gives you is there
necessarily communicate the overall
breadth of like the story line beyond
users rebels versus the empire and
whatnot or the first order whoever it is
I want to binge these movies before a
rise of Scott Walker comes out that's
what I'll do on vacation in Colorado at
the end of the month movie a day why
would I go explore the world that don't
live let's just watch movies in a living
room that's the point of vacations is to
do what you would at home just in a
nicer or more remove it area what I'll
do is I'll a marathon it a little
different I'll go Phantom Menace New
Hope Attack of the Clones Empire Strikes
Back
return the Jedi solo Star Wars story
rogue one all of the Clone Wars show
then maybe I'll watch Rises yeah maybe
if those rod Tomatoes reviews are good
and the Disney shills don't lie to us
again what's so good about these splices
too is that they make the bad ones look
good yeah my life at least in concept
what works about the overall scope of
this you're like well you do need that
movie that's like to think about it it
does fill in the context it does make it
more complete not a fan of those
prequels but they are essential viewing
they have a place now yeah which is nice
for yeah yeah I mean like I don't know
at a certain point yeah it's cool a lot
of people worked on those it's funny
like just this makes me think of so many
things of like how the original trilogy
is like historical filmmaking landmark
with this genuine heart and then the
prequels are these extended movies that
really don't want to rush to get to
Episode three that are just a crazy CGI
half-hearted written story
weird diplomatic exercises and then CGI
demo tutorials and then this latest
hirlaji is like the glossy nostalgia
version the version where were literally
watching them go how do we continue how
do we grow into something new there's
got to be some way to cut a little mini
see that other than just having a
marathon it but just really keeping the
essential stuff in you mean like a
Topher Grace cut of the Star Wars movies
the whole saga though like this where
I'm like yeah every movie has something
that is necessary but not the whole
movie if you did some kind of Hill a
house with all the icons they're
bringing back for the new wave you could
do like a hill house sort of thing where
you just cut back you know when you pass
that Vader a monument they have cut back
show some Anakin Sturm spliced it in
that way I gotta say about the 3 p.m.
moment that he did here because out of
all the trailers for rises Skywalker
weirdly the Threepio stuff it's been the
thing that's been standing out the one
with the red eyes reconnect that moment
was like I just wanted to take one last
look at you before I turn into the Iron
Giant yeah so the Threepio stuff ad I
thought it really knocked it out the
park here because you need that in order
especially when you're doing this
trailer cut in this style of Rises
Skywalker there's nothing else you can
really put there besides at 3:00 p.m. oh
but then flashing two moments with
Threepio would be like ogee cast yeah
and the only one that could really make
that work is the repeal because it looks
the same that's how this is Threepio saw
the whole time that's a great way to
reframe that maybe somebody will come
back in the future and make like a quiet
robot drama about Threepio being this
sort of historian of the Star Wars yeah
what the watchers are in the Marvel
Universe is what Threepio is yeah I've
watched this all unfold from the very
beginning since Vader made me is the
ancient one and that works too sure I
don't know
I already got my the more effort you got
it I got the watcher yeah you got the
Watchers all right I'm just trying to
get over who the watcher totally you
don't remember I do but I'm not gonna
tell you because maybe you're testing me
to tell you cuz you don't really know
and you just remember the name cuz
you're a fake fan you watch your history
I know I know but I there's so many tiny
the room yeah that's my that's my goal
here is to get us so down the rabbit
hole that no neither of us knows
I was willing to admit I know the
watcher is yeah I'm gonna am lien that
one post cameo scene in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 but he also plays a big
part in the The Watcher player part of
the Infinity Gauntlet comic alright
there you go
who watches The Watcher apparently me
only talking about this guys make sure
to subscribe to Alex Siegel
we're subscribing right now great job on
the edit there buddy you guys can
subscribe the real rejects please click
that notification bubble get notified
every time we got a youtube video up
Lance door Lance in my pants
give them Lance pants with the dance
trance got my Star Wars fans
Scott Manson I asked Lance knows
Halloween was he said that was actually
really fun community held a big
Halloween dance of prizes and activities
and it was a really fun time sounds like
fun
it's a firefighter orgy as well I could
describe it sounds like fun
well they're all wearing their suits and
they it is so heavy magic Lance triple
XL I want that movie yeah you get choose
either one of these moments the rhymes
are the let's make a calendar like gene
Jeter did he must every everybody
follows our genius of course I know do
you know or you've just testing me to
see if I know it was hella cheap do
either of us know gene gene was in the
post credit